il y en a assez de se la jouer chacun
pour soi chacun de son côté
la mutuelle des ménages prévoyante ce
sont des êtres humains et vous avant
tout en cas d'urgence vous pouvez
contacter notre assistance 24 heures sur
24 7 jours sur 7
parce que votre santé n'attend pas une
mutuelle qui répond toujours présent
c'est ça une mutuelle qui va bien
cliquez et vérifier le dès maintenant
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans chaque
oeuf votre émission santé et bien-être
au programme dans ce numéro nous
reviendrons sur les dons du sang après
les attentats du 13 novembre et
rappelleront l'importance d'une
mobilisation des donneurs tout au long
de l'année
nous parlerons également des aidants
familiaux et du programme de soutien qui
leur est destinée organisé par
l'association gère handicape depuis 2013
vous découvrirez ensuite ce qu'est la
thérapie par le rire hôpitaux les
bienfaits du rire grâce à l'association
karman
et pour finir découverte d'une pratique
assez particulière le soin psycho
capillaire il aurait l'occasion de
découvrir une dimension inattendue de la
coiffure
mais tout d'abord l'hôpital charcot
implantée à plaisir va subir un lifting
construit au début des années 60 les
quatre pavillons actuelle installés dans
le centre psychiatrique devons être
totalement réhabilité un bâtiment
flambant neuf de 14 mille mètres carrés
devraient sortir de terre en mars 2018
le projet était attendue depuis plus de
dix ans par les patients le directeur du
centre hospitalier jacques behra était
au micro de michael almy d'euros c'est
un grand soulagement c'est un chantier
qui qui est très atypique du fait de
nombreuses défections technique et
erreurs techniques juridiques et c'est
assez exceptionnel en france d'ailleurs
mais c'est un grand soulagement
effectivement pour l'équipe de direction
et pour aussi les personnes
de la direction et sa technique qui
travaille depuis des mois et des mois
pour faire redémarrer ce chantier chaque
année en france environ un million de
malades peuvent être soignés grâce aux
dons du sang pendant les périodes de
congés
les réserves en produits sanguins
subissent habituellement de fortes
baisses en plus des sites de collectes
fixes
l'établissement français du don du sang
compte sur la générosité des donneurs en
organisant des collectes mobiles comme
le 19 février à elancourt en forte
hausse après les tragiques attentats du
13 novembre une baisse du don du sang a
été enregistré trois mois plus tard à
elancourt une collectes mobiles
organisées en partenariat avec la ville
et l'établissement français du don du
sang est aussi là pour rappeler
l'importance de la mobilisation des
donneurs tout au long de l'année
une occasion pour rappeler à l'ensemble
des français enfin des habitants de la
france d'ailleurs que non du sang
c'était indispensable et que ce devait
être permanent il fallait pas attendre
de circonstances aussi épouvantable pour
donner son sang ce n'était pas une
publicité mais une bonne relance pour le
fait que le nom du sang était
indispensable pour pouvoir soigner un
ferme de pathologie et pas que des
blessés en plus des sites fixes ouverts
dans le département trois collectes
mobiles sont organisées chaque année à
elancourt une façon d'attirer
l'attention sur le besoin mais aussi de
permettre les dons aux habitants qui ne
peuvent se déplacer si ça peut motiver
certaines personnes qui le font pas à le
faire
c'est très bien moi après jeu dès que
j'ai l'occasion je donne n'était sur les
à donner son sang très rapidement après
les attentats parce que baffe
c'est la seule réponse qu'on pouvait
apporter un petit peu intelligente à ce
genre de ce genre de choses puis après
on sait qu il faut le faire tout le
temps régulièrement entre chaque don un
délai de trois mois est nécessaire d'où
l'importance de renouveler les donneurs
l'objectif pour 2016 52 mille poches de
sang a prélevé un défi relevé en 2015
avec 55 mille poches récoltées dans le
département les aidants familiaux ces
personnes qui soutiennent un proche
victimes de handicap ou de maladies sont
souvent trop seul face à cette lourde
tâche qui leur incombe depuis juin 2013
l'association gérant d'icap a lancé un
programme de soutien aux aidants avec
l'organisation de réunions de groupes de
parole ou d'ateliers thématiques
nous nous sommes rendus à une de ces
réunions qui avait pour thème
l'aromathérapie solitude et isolement
voilà à quoi sont confrontés les aidants
familiaux tous les jours aujourd'hui
réunies dans un entrée dans café
organisée par l'association gérondi cap
ils reçoivent conseils et informations
sur différentes techniques pouvant les
aider dans leurs problématiques
quotidiennes
aujourd'hui découverte de
l'aromathérapie l'aromathérapie c'est
l'utilisation de du l'essentiel d'huile
végétale de
de produits 100% naturels là on était
sur un format échanges plutôt découvrir
ce que les gens savent comment il
travaille avec réajuster parce qu'on a
vu qu'il ya un monsieur qui avait mis
pas mal de gouttes sur un mouchoir et
puis l'on il ya eu des réactions au
niveau de la peau donc c'est plutôt
donné une pratique sage et prudente et
sérieuse
un rendez vous pour les aidants qui fait
partie d'un programme particulier à
toutes les pratiques et groupes de
paroles sont également organisées tous
les ondes sa porte plusieurs choses déjà
de l'information ça leur permet de se
retrouver dans la pluralité des aides
il faut qu'ils sont proposés ça leur
permet de négocier retrouver de mieux
orienter leur leurs besoins et de savoir
à qui s'adresser dans leur situation
pour moi c'est l'occasion d'une part de
rencontrer des gens d'autres personnes
parce que je vis seul et et d'autre part
c'est aussi l'occasion de s'enrichir ses
connaissances un programme qui existe
depuis 2013 et qui permet surtout de
tisser un lien social en échangeant sur
les difficultés d'assister et d'aider un
proche dans tous les instants de la vie
le rire contribuerait au bien-être c'est
du moins ce que pensent plusieurs
thérapeute qui l'utilisent pour atténuer
la douleur mais aussi tisser un lien
social aux clayes-sous-bois
l'association car matt vient en aide aux
personnes âgées et handicapées de
différentes manières notamment par le
rire la présidente de l'association
marie thérèse rose donne des conférences
pour expliquer et démontrer les
bienfaits de ce procédé
rires mais surtout avec tout le monde
voilà le message que délivre
l'association qu'ahmad quai sous bois
rires pour aller mieux ou pour atténuer
la douleur
marie thérèse rose présidente de
l'association donne les clés de la
thérapie par le rire
laurie reproduit des tas de substance et
de neurotransmetteurs et d'euphorisants
qui permettent effectivement de lutter
contre le stress mais pas que ça ça peut
permettre aussi d'avoir une même une
meilleure digestion
parce que quand vous riez par exemple
c'est un exemple au kotel bouge donc
elle fut une sorte de massage sur
l'estomac l'intestin et le foie donc ça
fait des organes qui vaut mieux
fonctionner leur ira il est
indispensable à la vie
pour marie thérèse le rire joue sur la
qualité de vie et le bien-être
psychologique mais il est aussi vecteur
d'un lien social maryse rohff et donne
des cours de yoga du rire
un rire communicatif et même contagieux
et vous allez faire comme si vous
rugissiez comme un lion le yoga du rire
c'est d'abord la prise de conscience de
son corps et de sa verticalité sans
jugement simplement un ressenti de son
corps de toutes les parties de son corps
celui qui est vraiment et que nous
faisons régulièrement parce que je tiens
le faire c'est vraiment le rire du
d'union parce qu'il exprime vraiment
tout c'est vraiment la rolls royce du
rire aujourd'hui les français 10 de
moins en moins en moyenne une minute par
jour en 2015 contre une vingtaine en
1940 il ne tient plus qu'à vous
d'inverser cette tendance en le
propageant la manière de couper vos
cheveux pourrait avoir une répercussion
sur votre bien-être intérieur
c'est en tout cas l'objectif de la coupe
de cheveux énergétique
une méthode inventée par rémy portrait
qui se développe de plus en plus
aujourd'hui cette pratique à gérer sur
la libération de mémoire cellulaire du
corps aux clayes-sous-bois sophie lebouc
pratique la coupe de cheveux énergétique
depuis huit ans de manière
professionnelle et nous a ouvert les
portes de son cabinet je vais faire
passer une vibration en montant comme ça
votre cheveu
c'est une méthode qui peut paraître tiré
par les cheveux mais ici
on les écoute plutôt en quatre sophie
lebouc pratique la coupe énergétique
depuis huit ans une technique de
bien-être psycho capillaire c'est
premièrement faire de la musique avec
les cheveux voilà et c'est travailler
sur la déprogrammation cellulaire donc
le principe en fait de tendre les
cheveux donc les cordes et d'émettre une
vibration avec mes coaches où les coûts
sont les lames utilisé par sophie pour
tailler les cheveux des lames de 7 cm
représentant sept notes de musique par
la vibration contact du cheveu cette
vibration elle va aller aussi contacter
le cortex donc le cortex c'est la
membrane qui entoure les deux lobes du
cerveau ça passait par les oreilles
interne et ça va passer par le liquide
céphalo rachidien
c'est pour ça que ça fait partie en fait
des techniques où le mental il peut pas
intervenir c'est le corps qui lâche qui
peut au moment où il peut le cheveu et
ishi diriger un baromètre du court pour
calmer ou stimuler les organes c'est
vrai que le cheveu c'est le baromètre
justement parce que ils pompent le sang
il se nourrit du sang donc bas suivant
si on est en carence si on un prêt de
savoir quand même que le cheveu quand il
ya un problème au niveau d'un organe en
habit sert le cheveu lui c'est le
premier au courant parce que le sens il
est vicié et donc le cheveu lui il le
sait déjà
j'ai détesté les coiffeurs longtemps
parce qu'il faut il vous écoute pas ils
vous entende pas quand je sors d'ici je
vais mieux
donc c'est quand même plutôt bien ce qui
devrait être ordinaire d'un coiffeur
mais ce qui n'est pas la coupe
énergétique une technique française
inventé par rémy portrait qui est pour
l'instant le seul à dispenser cette
formation une méthode basée sur l'écouté
du corps pour une meilleure harmonie et
bien-être
et pour terminer vous l'attendiez même
certainement alors tous à vos crayons
voici l'agenda avec deux dates à retenir
tout d'abord rendez-vous à fontenay le
fleury le jeudi 10 mars pour la journée
mondiale de l'audition avec des ateliers
de sensibilisation en présence d'un
audioprothésiste pour s'informer sur
l'impact des nuisances sonores sur la
santé pour en savoir plus rendez vous
sur le site internet
et puis ensuite direction trappe le 11
mars pour un dépistage du caudan car
gratuit en présence d'un dentiste de
l'union française du coc dentaires ainsi
qu'un référent santé de la ville qui
vous aidera à engager les démarches
liées aux soins pour en profiter rendez
vous dès 16 heures au centre
socioculturel
annette moreau voilà check up c'est
maintenant terminé quant à moi il ne me
reste plus qu'à vous dire dans deux
semaines pour un prochain numéro
et surtout d'ici là prenez femme vous